[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN AHARON: Speech at Google--
it's been a long journey.
So we originally developed
voice search for Google Search--
I think it was
over 15 years ago.
And then we kind of
took that technology
and brought it to other
products like Google Maps--
for voice search in
maps for navigation--
and text-to-speech
for navigation.
And captions in YouTube and
Google Assistant-- and we
invested all that effort
into building a robust speech
engine that can work across
a large number of languages
and doesn't need as much
tuning as technology
that existed at the time all
based on machine learning.
And then we took that
technology-- three years ago--
and we brought it to the
cloud for the first time
with Cloud Speech-to-Text as
part of our developer products.
Oh, can we go back to a slide?
Yeah, it's OK.
So speech-to-text and
then text-to-speech--
they're our developer products.
So you can use them to
power all the applications
you build with AI technology.
And then last year, we
introduced our business
solutions--
which are higher-level
of abstraction,
which include Dialogflo
and Contact Center AI.
There's going to be a
session about those tomorrow.
So you're welcome
to check it out.
They take some of
the technologies
we expose in speech-to-text
and text-to-speech
and apply them to
specific use cases
like chat bots and voice
bots and the Contact Center.
So you can use them
in more places.
So as I mentioned, we
have two products in Cloud
with the raw speech
capabilities that
are leveraged everywhere else.
Speech-to-Text is available
in 120 languages--
so, far more than any
other speech service
that's available today.
And it provides service
in real-time streaming
as well as batch.
One of the things that is
special-- it performs really
well in noisy environments.
We'll see if I'll regret
saying that when we actually
do some demos later.
But typically-- it's trained
on a lot of noisy data.
So it performs well,
even if there's
traffic in the background, or
people speaking, or whatever.
And Text-to-Speech, it's
the only production service
out there with WaveNet.
We'll see later why
that actually matters.
It's available in 21
languages, but there's
going to be more coming
later in text and SSML.
So since we first came
out with Speech-to-Text,
there's been a lot of new
development in this space.
As you can see here,
we took it to GA.
We improved accuracy.
We improved the speed.
And then we introduced a bunch
of new features like language
auto-detect, word-level
confidence, timestamps--
then in February,
two months ago,
we came out with a
bunch of new launches.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit more about them next.
So we wanted to make our speech
products more accessible.
And we're doing
that in three ways.
One is we're making
the premium models that
were only available
to select groups
now available to everyone.
Two, we're reducing prices
on some of our products
by up to 50%.
And three, we're increasing
language support, especially
for Text-to-Speech.
So a little bit on the premium
models-- so as I mentioned,
the core speech-recognition
technology in Cloud
was based on the
technology that Google
developed for other products.
But what we quickly found out
is the Cloud developers weren't
just applying them
on the same use cases
that Google Search,
or Google Assistant,
or the Google products
used, but actually
for a lot of enterprise
applications--
so like transcribing
phone calls,
for IVRs, or for
indexing videos,
or adding subtitles to
videos, or transcribing
meetings, or all of
these other use cases.
And so we invested
specific effort
for improving
these cloud models.
And this resulted in
our premium models
that were launched in beta--
I think it was--
April last year-- so
exactly one year ago.
So these premium models improved
performance by 64% and 62%.
So this is the percentage
of reduction in error.
So you could argue it's 2x to 3x
better than what existed before
for these specific
mediums because there
was a concerted
effort on these areas.
And then when they launched,
and [INAUDIBLE] phone_call model
was based on data from opt-in
customers in Cloud that
gave us the permission use their
data to improve the models.
So we only made it available
for others that also contributed
for that program.
And now, we're sort of
opening it up further.
So I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
But first, let's
switch to the demo.
I can show you guys--
we get a lot of questions
from people about.
Oh, I think it's showing
the wrong screen.
Do I need to change something?
Actually, maybe I drag it?
KEVIN NORTHOVER:
That's the other demo.
DAN AHARON: No,
that's the wrong one.
Switch back?
Yeah, maybe if I drag
my screen over here?
Does that work?
Sorry, guys.
Let me change my display
settings so that it's mirrored.
Mirror displays.
OK, I think it's showing now.
So a lot of people ask us--
they tell us we already
use speech recognition.
And we know that Google
speech recognition is better.
But what we have is
good enough for us.
What's happening is
speech recognition
is used in more and
more use cases today.
And the bar is actually
getting higher.
So you can see here--
this is an example
of a conversation
with a voice bot
where you're getting
100% accuracy.
And you can see--
you can build a very
delightful experience
for users when everything
is working properly, right.
So this is an example of someone
ordering a burger and the voice
bot responding.
And everything works great.
But then if you go down to
a lower level of accuracy,
even at 90%--
which for harsh
conditions, is actually
be considered pretty good--
that means that in a
utterance with 40 words,
you'll get four of
them were wrong.
And there is a very
high likelihood
that those four words--
some of them will encompass
things that you actually
really care about.
And the bot will fail, which
will lead the users to be
a little frustrated.
Because they actually
need to repeat
stuff that they've
already said before.
So it's not a great
user experience.
And this is even at 90%.
But then, imagine
what would happen
if this goes down a little
bit further into 80%, right?
You'll see that in a second.
It becomes sort of inoperable.
Right, so if you were to say--
a few years ago--
80% or 90% accuracy
for recognizing speech,
people would be pretty happy.
But now there's a
higher bar for this.
By the way, this also applies
to Google products, right.
So with Google Assistant,
the bar for voice recognition
is much higher than
it used to be when
we were doing voice search.
OK, let's go back to the slides.
So the premium models for
better speech recognition--
the phone one was only available
for people that shared audio.
Now we've made it
available for everyone.
And then for people that
enable data logging--
as an opt-in feature--
they're now all getting
discounted usage.
So everyone's getting
a benefit, whether they
share data or don't share data.
We're here to provide the
best service either way.
Cool.
Let's talk a little bit
about Text-to-Speech.
So we introduced Cloud
Text-to-Speech that's
based on WaveNet last year.
You can see, here,
a survey we ran
on the quality of the voices.
And what you see here is
four different voices.
And the left column
shows the standard voice.
The middle is the WaveNet.
And the right one is human.
So if you look at the
yellow one, for example,
which is the third.
The standard is 3.65.
The human is 4.59, you
can see WaveNet is 4.28.
So it's really, really close.
Let's switch to the demos.
So if we go here,
and we type something
like, Hi to the audience at the
session of Google Cloud Next.
And now, let me play
this to you guys with--
this is now standard voice.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hi to the audience at the
session of Google Cloud Next.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAN AHARON: So you can see--
you can hear what he
says very clearly, right?
You can understand
every single word.
But it sounds a little robotic.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hi to the audience at the
session of Google Cloud Next.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAN AHARON: Now, if we switch
to the WaveNet equivalent--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hi to the audience at the
session of Google Cloud Next.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAN AHARON: So you can see--
it's worlds apart, right?
And when you use this for
long texts and play it,
I sometimes can't
tell the difference.
It sounds to me like an
NPR News broadcaster.
It's getting pretty
close to what you would
hear on the radio or whatever.
Back to the slides.
So WaveNet is really cool.
But the problem is it's
hugely compute-intensive.
So in order to generate
a WaveNet sample,
for every single
second of audio,
we need to run 22,000 inferences
on a very heavy neural network.
And that was a huge
engineering challenge.
Originally, it took
a long time to do.
But then our team spent
pretty significant effort,
figuring out how to optimize it.
And the Google team
came up with a way
to do it 1,000 times faster.
And this is building on
the infinite computing
power we have with TPUs--
tensor processing
units-- and other things
that are ML-specialized.
It lets you run much, much
faster and much better.
And we were able to do it at
scale, in a way that it's now
possible in the industry.
And then, just a
few weeks ago, we
announced a huge
expansion of our voices.
So we've now doubled the
number of WaveNet voices.
And if you look back
to April last year,
we had six WaveNet voices--
only in English-US.
We now have 57 WaveNet voices--
I think in pretty much all of
the languages you see here.
And there's going to be more
coming soon later in the year.
So we have full coverage.
So it's by far more than
anything else, that's
out there-- we're very excited
about WaveNet in the future.
And then to wrap it up, the
other announcement we had
was a bunch of features--
we announced it
went to GA, which
means general availability.
That means that they're
covered under our SLA agreement
and are considered
production-ready.
So Text-to-Speech--
as a product--
went GA last year.
And then Audio
profiles, which lets
you tune the Text-to-Speech
audio to the medium and a bunch
of these Speech-to-Text
features-- model
selection, our premium models,
multi-channel recognition,
audio logging.
OK, so to make this
interesting, we
wanted to talk to you a
little bit about new features
that are about to come soon.
Now this is not
something we typically
do in all of our
sessions here at Next.
But we wanted to keep it
interesting for you guys
and give you a sense
of what's coming next.
The balance of it is
some of these things
might change before you
actually see them officially
launched out in production.
So we would love to
still hear your feedback
if you have any ideas
of how to improve these.
But we're going to show you
how they look right now.
So we're going to talk about
the two main groups of use cases
that we serve with
speech recognition.
So the first is
human-computer interaction.
That's kind of the traditional
investment of speech at Google.
And then the second is
human-to-human interaction.
So you could think
about analyzing
phone calls between a
customer and an agent,
or analyzing meetings,
or things like that--
where you're talking about
speech between multiple people.
So we're going to
have new developments
for each of these two to
talk about a little bit.
Let's start with the first one.
So we've had something called
phrase hints in our API
for a long while now.
The problem is it's really
hard to get it right, right?
Sorry, actually, let me
first describe what it does.
What phrase hints does is
it allows you to customize
the API to specific phrases.
So if you have specific product
names, or company names,
or other things
that you're looking
for that you expect
users might say,
you can add that to the
recognition command.
And then it will improve
recognition quality.
The trouble is it could also
increase false positives.
If you add a string, it might
start recognizing that string
even if it wasn't said.
So by default, it's actually--
it's set to be pretty weak.
So that's a problem.
The other problem is
you need to come up
with different phrases for
everything you want to send.
So we're going to come out
with a few features that
address this.
First is what we call strength.
So as you can see
in blue over there,
we're going to give
you the opportunity
to set the strength for
each speech context.
And so you can set it
much stronger than what
we made available up until now.
And it makes it
much more useful.
You'll be able to see that
in a demo in a few minutes.
The second is classes.
So for things like
month, for example.
If you just tell us that
you're looking for a month,
we can figure out
what's behind it--
you don't need to spell out
all of the different months--
January and February, et cetera.
So here's an example
list of classes.
And we'll share the final
one when this is ready to go.
But these can help you with your
different recognition tasks.
OK, let's switch to the demo.
OK, here it is.
So here-- just as an example--
there's a sequence of
digits that we recorded.
Let me play it to you.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- 31378654.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAN AHARON: So you can
kind of understand what
I'm saying in this recording.
Then if you look
at this other one,
you can see it's very noisy.
So it's actually really hard
to tell what the digits are.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- 31378654.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAN AHARON: OK, so if you
take the original one--
let me just change this.
If you take the original one,
and you send it to the API,
then we'll see it recognizes it
properly, with 100% accuracy.
Recognizing a digit sequence is
pretty hard, by the way, right?
Because even if you
get one of them wrong,
the whole string is wrong.
So in a way, it's
like a full sentence.
Now let's try the
same on the noisy one.
So I just sent a cURL
command, like you see here.
And you can see, it
recognizes incorrectly.
So it says, we went three
78654, because it doesn't really
know that it should expect
a sequence of digits.
So here, what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to use the class
operand, which means a digit--
I'm going to tell it it
should expect a sequence
of eight consecutive digits.
I'm going to send it over.
And you can see, it still
didn't change the result.
The reason is it's still using
relatively weak speech context.
So now, when I also
add strength high--
like you can see here in blue--
we can try it again.
And you can see, now it
actually recognizes it
with 100% accuracy.
So that's speech context
strength and classes, guy's.
So just as a disclaimer--
it doesn't always work right.
Speech recognition is a
little bit of a science
and a little bit of an art.
There's going to
be cases where you
want to force it to
recognize digits,
but it'll recognize
something else.
And there's going to be
cases where it recognizes
it too strong, right?
So it falsely recognizes digits
when you don't want it to.
So these are things that allow
you a little bit more control
to play with the API and
reach the settings that
are optimal for you.
So for each use case, it
might be a little different.
OK, let's talk about the
second major use case, which
is human-to-human interaction.
And there, we've had streaming
for a long period of time,
but streaming is
limited to one minute.
We do have LongRunningRecognize
that could use any length
that you want, but it
doesn't work in real time.
The problem of speech
analytics usually
requires long audio files.
So if it's a phone
call recording,
it could be five
minutes or 10 minutes.
If it's a meeting, it
could be multiple hours.
If it's a movie could
be multiple hours.
So what we're coming out
with is a new feature,
called ResultEndTime.
And what it does-- it tells
you how far the recognition
happened so far.
And then you can
restart a new session
from where the last one ended.
So you can restart a
session whenever you want
and still get 100%
of the same results
as if you were going more.
So let me show you
how this actually
looks like in real life.
OK, so what you see
here in this demo--
I can make this
maybe a bit bigger.
Here, we asked it to
restart every 10 seconds.
So every 10 seconds,
it basically closes
the streaming connection
and starts a new streaming
connection.
So right now, the API
supports up to 60 seconds.
So if I didn't use any timer,
it would just go up until 60.
But in order to make the
demo more interesting,
we set it to 10
to make it easier.
I'm going to click Start.
And now you can see--
it's listening to me.
And it's showing
these red boxes.
So the red box--
you can see-- is turning
into green once it
detects an end of an utterance.
Oh, it's not a good combination
with me talking in the echo--
I see.
But you can see it's
turning into green once it
detects an end of utterance.
And you can--
[LAUGHTER]
--yeah, that's nice.
The yellow boxes show
where it's restarting.
And so you can see
the actual audio
is not impacted by
when it restarts.
If I keep on
talking now, you can
see that it keeps
on the recognition,
even though it's a whole
new streaming session.
Right, it keeps on with all
of the same data that it had.
So you can see it
carries over, right?
So with this method, you can
basically do endless streaming
for as long as you want.
Let me show you how that looks
like in the command line mode.
So I'm going to talk now.
And now I'm going to talk again.
And let's see--
OK, you can see
it did a restart.
And it didn't impact
the recognition.
By the way, I was standing--
at the mic is on my laptop.
I was standing a little
further out from the laptop.
So that probably reduces
results a little bit.
Wow, that was a really
long, utterance.
OK, so thank you.
So that's endless streaming.
How many developers do
we have in the audience?
Who wants to see the code
that's powering this demo?
OK, a lot of hands up there.
OK, let's do it.
The only caveat is I
didn't write this code,
so I'll do my best
to give it justice.
But please forgive
me if I don't do it.
So this is then code in Node.js.
Can you guys see?
Or should I make it bigger?
Is that better?
OK, let me scroll
down to the bottom,
because that's
where the action is.
So here in the
bottom, you can see
what it does is it
starts a record session.
And they use a
program called rec,
which is from the SoX family.
And it uses that to
capture audio from the mic.
And then it sends it into
audio stream transform,
which is a transform
stream, something
that's readable and writeable.
And then, it calls something
called startStream().
So let's scroll up
to startStream().
And what startStream() does
is it starts in audio array.
And then it starts a new
streamingRecognize session.
So this just calls the
Speech-to-Text API.
And then it sends
all the data that's
coming in to speechCallback.
And then, here,
you set a timeout,
so you restart the stream.
This is the 10 seconds
that we had in our demo.
So let's take a look
at speechCallback.
What speechCallback does--
it gets the resultEndTime
from the API.
This is what we
talked about earlier.
And then it calculates
the correct time.
So here in the demo,
you can see there's
a corrected time, which is--
you need to know that it's 60
seconds from when we started
the demo, not just the offset
from where we currently
are in the current array.
So it calculates that
and prints it out.
And then it looks
for an isFinal.
If it gets isFinal,
that's the flag
that says the end of
utterance was detected.
So you can mark it as green.
Or otherwise, it keeps
using the same audio buffer
and then marks it as red.
Then, let's look
at the callback--
that's another
interesting important one.
So here, what it
does is it calculates
what we call chunkTime.
It's basically the size
of an audio array element.
So you take the full
streaming limit,
divide by the length
of the audio array,
and then you get what is
the size of each element
in the array-- or a chunk.
And then with that
chunk, you calculate
how many chunks you need to
grab from the previous array
and how many chunks you need to
grab from the current, array--
so lastAudioArray.length.
This tells you-- it's like here.
You can see-- you
need this part, right?
When you go, after
the yellow part--
this part-- you need
to grab the audio that
came before the yellow.
So that's what's
being done here.
You take it from lastAudioArray.
And then you recognize it.
And then, the last important
thing to watch out for
is this restart function.
So it's really important
to run removeListener().
If you don't do
that, then you'll
have two listeners
running in the background.
So every time you
restart a stream,
you need to remove the listener
and not just set it to null.
And that's it.
There's a restart counter,
so it knows how many times
it did 10 seconds.
And that's it.
So that's endless
streaming, guys.
Thanks.
So just to talk a little bit
about limitations with the demo
you just saw.
So it handles two arrays--
two audio arrays.
And we set each
one to 10 seconds.
You can set them for
longer if you want.
But in this demo, if you talk
more than 20 seconds at a time,
it won't be able
to capture that,
because it's only set up to
take to capture 20 seconds.
The other thing is that it does
arithmetic on the audio array,
based on the length of
time that has passed.
So it works well for
a constant bit rate.
So LINEAR16 is fine.
Mulaw is also fine-- even
though it's compressed,
it's still a constant bit rate.
But if you try MP3 and stuff
like that, it won't work.
Luckily, there is very
little real-time streaming
that people do with MP3, right?
Because you'd have to compress
it in real-time as well.
And the other thing to
note-- diarization context
is actually important.
And if you restart a stream,
it resets that context.
So if you want to
do diarization,
this will impact those results.
The other thing is
this is available here
in the Node.js client library.
We're going to add it to
all of our client libraries
eventually, but they're
not all available yet.
So this is something
that you'll need to check
before you start using it.
Cool.
So let's transition
to talk a little bit
about speech analytics.
So there's a lot
of cool things you
could do with speech analytics,
especially in call centers--
so understanding
customer sentiment,
understanding why
users are calling.
Figuring out how to reduce
call volume or how to upsell--
like if a customer is
asking for a product that's
out of inventory or stuff like
that and you want to follow up.
There's like all these cool
analyses you want to do.
But it's actually
non-trivial to set it up.
Actually, could we switch
to the other slide?
Let me go forward.
So there's a lot of
technical steps involved,
and very typically, when
we talk to customers,
they love our technology--
they love our AI.
But in order to actually
take advantage of it,
they need to go to
the IT department
and ask them to build
something for them.
Or they need to an SI to build
a visualization platform.
Just having access to
the API is not enough.
So we want to help with that.
And a way to do that is with
what we are calling the speech
analytics framework.
So this is kind of like
a design pattern of how
to do analysis on speech.
And we're showing an
example of how it could
apply for the call center.
But you could also apply
it in any other use case.
So you can see the audio comes
into Google's Cloud Storage.
And then it gets processed
with Cloud Functions.
Cloud Functions then uses
are different AI tools--
Speech API, Natural
Language API, AutoML--
to understand what's actually
in those audio files.
And then that data gets sent--
through Cloud Pub/Sub and
DataFlow-- into BigQuery.
DataFlow handles the
streaming information,
and then it gets
stored in BigQuery,
which can do the analysis.
It can help us run queries
and better understand
what's in those audio files.
And then we have a
visualization layer.
The one we're showing
here was built in React,
but you could build whatever you
want in whatever tool you want.
And Identity Aware
Proxy for security,
which leads you to the final
result in the visualization.
And you're going to see
a demo and a little bit.
It's pretty cool.
What we want is for
any cloud customer
to be able to get from
having audio files to this
in two weeks.
And we're setting
up a program where
you can ask for help with SIs or
whatever to help you get there.
So to elaborate a little
bit more about that,
let me invite Kevin-- he's
going to talk lots more.
KEVIN NORTHOVER: All right.
Well, thank you, Dan.
It's great to be here and to be
able to talk to you about what
we've been doing at Delta
Dental with the tools
Dan has been telling us about.
Good, yeah, getting
those back up.
All right.
So we're a health
insurance payer.
That means we have two
large communities of users--
the members, like you or I,
who get dental treatment.
And it's covered
by a plan that's
either employer-funded or
increasingly one that we
bought ourselves on
the individual market.
And the dentists themselves.
We cover about 1.7
million members.
The bulk of those,
obviously, are
in New Jersey and Connecticut.
But we cover people
all over the country.
For example, we have 100,000
members here in California.
And we're part of a larger
network of Delta Dental
companies-- there are
nearly 30 in all, which
cover 73 million Americans.
And the association
also provides
some central, national services.
The obvious one is
simply a directory
of practicing dentists that
we all need to process claims.
So why the call center?
Somebody said in the
keynote this morning--
the call center is still
really the primary point
of contact for many
companies for many of users.
And it's particularly true for
us with members and dentists.
We do a lot of calls--
about 4,300 hours a month.
That's about 4,000 calls a day.
All right?
And 3/4 of our calls come
from dentists' offices.
And usually those are
questions about benefits
eligibility-- does
this person who's just
walked in the door
have insurance?
Has their insurance expired?
Or it can get down
to the procedures.
Is their children's
retainer covered?
When can I get my
crown replaced?
All of these kinds
of questions come up.
In other words, what's
the coverage in the plans.
And as we all know-- from our
medical and dental experience--
plans vary.
So that's one thing we know from
talking to the customer center.
The other thing we know-- from
looking at our phone logs--
is that most of our
calls are short.
That spike you see in the
histogram on the right
is centered on 80 seconds.
It's actually 65
to 95 seconds wide.
And the interesting
thing about that
is that in that length
of time, you only
have time to cover one subject.
So from the point of view of
someone doing a data science
and modeling analysis,
that's a very nice,
clean data set to work with.
And the analytics results
I'm going to show you--
so far-- are all based
on analyzing what's
going on there in detail.
We figured if we understand
single subjects well,
we'll be able to get into
the more complicated subjects
in the longer course.
So the first thing we did
was take the Speech-to-Text
from Dan's tools and run it
through the natural language
processing.
And natural language--
the sentiment analysis
will give you back a sentiment
score for every sentence
in the transcript.
And if you really want
to test Dan's stuff,
try saying that sentence fast.
Ha.
OK.
And what we then did was
marry that back to the word
timings that we get from
the Speech-to-Text and plots
the distribution of sentiment
as it tracks through a call.
What you can see is that
these are not movie reviews.
There's no one number that
characterizes the call.
What we have, though,
is a great tool
for pulling apart the
structure of a conversation.
And we can see all
the patterns that you
would like to see in any kind
of customer service call show
up immediately in the sentiment.
Right, but it's not
very useful for getting
quantitative results.
So what do you do?
You have to get a
bit more subtle.
What we did was split the
calls out by type of caller.
So look at the top
two rows first.
In the left column, we have
dental offices and members
that we talked about earlier.
We have the same sentiment
plots for each of those--
these ones are actually
three month averages.
On the right hand side,
which we plot the residuals--
we subtracted the
average sentiment profile
from the individual classes.
And you can see,
now, we actually have
something that we can model.
We can fit a straight
line to this data.
And it's a pretty good fit.
The pale blue bars and
95% confidence limits.
So two things are obvious.
One is that members and
dentists are different.
Either dentists
are a gloomy lot,
or we're continually
giving them bad news
about how much of
the procedure they
want to do is actually covered.
But we're doing quite
well with members,
and the sentiment is generally
rising through the call.
The bottom row-- it turns out
that some of our major accounts
have a specific
phone line for them.
So we can identify
a major account.
And we give the same number to
the dentists and the members.
So you'd expect those calls
to split the difference.
And they do, very nicely.
So what this is telling us
is not necessarily anything
we can immediately use directly.
But it's telling us that there
is real structure in the calls.
And it is worth analyzing
them in more depth.
And we're starting to do.
One of the things
we've started recently
is we've turned on the
premium phone model.
And we're now running
speaker diarization.
And so the next
generation of these plots
will actually separate
out the sentiment
profile for the caller
and the sentiment
profile for the agent.
Talking of agents, you can
do the same thing for agents.
The first time I showed
this plot to our customer
service team leaders, I hadn't
anonymized the agent names.
And the immediate
reaction of one
of the team leaders
to the top one
was, she's no longer
with the company.
Right.
The nice thing about that
is that was a huge win.
Because it gives you
instant credibility
with the business user that
the kind of measurements
you're making on this data--
that seem to be very abstract--
are actually
measuring real things
they're seeing in dealing
with their employees.
So, nice one.
The other, next
metric we looked at
was something that isn't there--
the dead air between calls.
All conversation has
natural rhythms in it
and there are pauses--
they vary in length.
This is a standard metric
in call centers-- obviously,
you want your people talking.
We got asked to do this,
by the call center,
because they had an
agent who they'd noticed
had a lot of dead air-- a lot
of pauses in the conversation.
And so you can see that
in the plot on the right.
The other thing
you can also see is
that the call structure shows
up in exactly the same way
in the dead air--
the familiar phrases,
the opening greeting,
and the end of the call,
we don't pause very much.
When we're thinking about
working an issue, we do.
This has been an enormously
valuable metric for us.
We've used it in customer
service for coaching agents.
We have done tests,
instrumenting
the agent's desktop, and been
able to show that our agents--
in the long pauses, when
they're working an issue--
are looking at applications
like sticky notes and Outlook.
They're looking up information
in their personal knowledge
repositories.
That tells us what we have
to build next for them.
We also instrumented it to test
whether dual monitors would
improve-- so we
can quantitatively
see impacts in the
customer center
just from these very
simple measurements.
And that's one of
the points that I
hope comes out of this--
that once you have
all the sophisticated
technology of speech
detection, natural
language, you're
able to ask very simple
business-oriented questions
and get good answers.
Another metric-- we've
worked on topic modeling,
but we haven't yet got
any very good results.
And we're about to go through
another iteration of that.
Topic modeling, for
us, is really hard.
Because-- you saw-- we
had benefits eligibility
earlier on.
That's a huge subject.
We need to be able to get to the
second tier and do it reliably.
But there are some things you
can do just by counting words.
In this particular
case, we had a change
that had been talked
about in the organization
for a long time.
We wanted to change
some procedures.
We could never make
the business case.
By just counting
those two words--
across a sample of transcripts--
we were able to
make the business
case to change the IVR system.
That change will roll out
at the end of this month.
We expect that to cut the number
of calls we have by about 20%.
In a year, that will pay for
our investment in this project.
Now, this situation may
not apply in your business,
but we're pretty sure-- from
what we've been finding,
looking at the
transcripts in depth--
that everybody has some
kind of problem like this.
There's something there, but
it's buried at the moment.
And the last one-- tying
back to IVR systems again--
is how many people here like
going through long IVR menus?
Right.
Well, it shows up when you talk
to the agent at the end of it.
And we can measure that.
And we tied back the
sentiment scores--
and particularly the negative
sentences in the call--
to the path through
the IVR system.
So keep them short.
OK, that's some of
the examples analytics
we've been able to
do on this data.
Now I'd like to go a
little bit technical
and talk about
how we built this.
We built it in a framework
that's very like the one
that Dan just outlined to you.
We upload our recordings
into the cloud.
And then when you
upload the recording
to the storage bucket, it
triggers a Cloud Function.
This entirely
serverless pipeline--
it's scalable, horizontally
and vertically.
Once that Cloud Function
finishes processing,
the transcribe interface
writes the output back,
as the transcript record,
into the same storage bucket.
It triggers another instance
of the Cloud Function.
And we just cascade
through those instances
until we've got all
our processing done.
All right.
We've found that this is a
very reliable way of doing it.
It's straightforward to deploy.
It runs very well.
We can scale it vertically.
And it scales very well
with increasing volumes
in a single project.
It's also easy to
scale horizontally.
If we've got a slightly
different problem
we want to work on or we want to
process a data set for somebody
else, we just spin
up another project,
install all the
software, and go.
And because it's all
Cloud Function-based,
it's a quick deployment.
We can spin up a
project in three hours.
And it only takes that long
because I haven't finished
writing the automation script.
So again-- a little bit
about how we build this.
We develop in Python.
We wrap all the Google APIs
in our own Python classes.
And we use those
exclusively for the cloud
and the on-premise applications.
This really reduces
the amount of effort
we have to put in on building
out a new application to handle
configuration
exceptions, retries,
all those kinds of things.
It also turns out to be
really essential for handling
the results.
Speech-to-Text gives
the results back
in a very natural format
for Speech-to-Text--
their word timings
and their words.
Natural Language gives us
back the sentiment analysis
in the natural format.
It's sentences in
character offset,
because when they built that,
they didn't have word timings
information.
We have to cross-reference
all of those.
And we've found this as we've
looked into other Google APIs--
that there's a lot of work in
just integrating all of this
together.
OK.
What I'd like to do now
is run a short demo.
Dan talked about
the visualizations.
OK, if you could cut
it over, thank you.
All right.
So this is running on a
data set in the cloud in one
of our Cloud projects.
And the data volume--
you can see the
call volume here--
I pulled a week of call data to
build this top-level template.
So this is a real week
from about three weeks ago.
And you can see, we've
got an average sentiment
over all the calls.
We've got the average agent
talk time, client talk time,
silence, and so on.
We can go down.
We can plot this.
You can see the timelines.
You can see that
our customer service
center is open from
7:00 AM to 9:00 PM,
but very few people
call after 6 PM.
All right.
And below that, we
have the call log.
We can pick out a
particular call.
We built-- obviously, it's on
the Google Cloud Platform--
there's got to be a search
engine in there somewhere.
And we have the
ability to do search.
This, at the moment,
is just a dummy.
We haven't hooked up the full
text search on the database.
And it wouldn't actually be that
useful, because for this demo,
I had to use redacted
transcripts-- we're a HIPAA
company.
And I've only got two of
them redacted in here.
So the Word Cloud works.
You can see the evidence
of the redaction--
now, the tags come in, but
if you click on a word,
it'll rearrange for you.
But with only two recordings in
there, it doesn't change much.
And then finally, the idea is
that a customer service team
leader will be able to
use this kind of dashboard
and drill into a
particular call.
And we can do that as well.
It takes a moment to load.
You can see-- we've got the
same kind of parameter sets
up at the top.
They're just the measurements
for the individual call.
And then we have the
sentiment time line here.
So this is something
that makes specific--
for an individual call--
the aggregate graph
I showed you earlier.
And it's a useful tool.
So here, we've got a
large negative sentiment.
What went on?
Let's get this.
So there-- and brings up the
sentence down the bottom.
And it's not really emotional
negative sentiment here.
This is factual, right?
One of the problems about
doing this only on text is you
don't--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Only $30 were
covered, and that's
why we sent you
that check for $30.
- So that's the only
thing Delta paid?
- Exactly, the other--
[END PLAYBACK]
KEVIN NORTHOVER:
So our agent wasn't
being emotionally negative, but
it was negative information.
That's where we run into the
limits of dealing with text,
and we would need
another method.
There's other tools
we've got in here.
And I've got just
over two minutes left.
I'm sorry.
So we're looking at
the entity transcript.
We can pull up things
like the organization
and highlight those
in the whole text.
And below that,
obviously, at some point,
you want to look at the
listing of the call.
And we have the
diarized listing, which
is tagged by agent and client.
And obviously we can
identify the agent,
because for us, the initial
greeting is fairly standard.
Right.
So one final thing--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- You're very welcome.
I hope you have a great day.
Thank you for calling.
You have a happy new year.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- Bye bye.
[END PLAYBACK]
KEVIN NORTHOVER: And with
that, it's back to you, Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN AHARON: Thank you, Kevin.
Can we go back to the slides?
So I see that,
and I get excited.
So it's pretty amazing that you
could do that in two weeks--
basically, go from audio to
having a complete dashboard
with visualization of
everything that you want.
It's clearly not enough
to do everything you would
need in a large call center.
But we have a lot of partners
that can help turn it
into whatever you need.
So if you're interested in more
information about the Speech
Analytics Framework,
there's a link at the top.
Just go to bit.ly/s-a-f.
All of the components
that we talked about today
are all available in our larger
solution for contact centers,
called Contact Center AI.
That's the URL for that.
There's also a session
about it tomorrow.
So please go there if you want
more information about that.
And then if you want to learn
more about Endless Streaming
and the new SpeechContext
features we demoed
at the beginning, go do that
bit.ly/GCP-Next19-Speech,
and if you sign up there, then
we'll send you information when
it's available to test.
So we have a half minute.
Do you guys want to try
one more bonus demo?
AUDIENCE: Go for it.
DAN AHARON: OK, let's
try to do it quickly.
Can we switch back
to the demos, please?
OK.
So does someone here speak a
language other than English?
Yeah, which language?
AUDIENCE: Spanish.
DAN AHARON: OK, let's
test this with Spanish.
Welcome, everyone,
to Google Cloud Next,
and I hope you're having a great
week here in San Francisco.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[END PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
DAN AHARON: How was it?
It was accurate?
OK.
So what you're seeing
here is three things--
Speech-to-Text together
with Cloud Translation
and then Text-to-Speech
all coming together
to be your real time translator.
And what I want
to show you now--
there's this cool device.
You can't really see it for
those that are far away.
But I'm holding a small
device in my hand.
And it's from a company
called Sourcenext.
They released this device,
and I'm going to talk to it
right now,
I'm holding this cool
device in my hand.
And I'm wondering
what it can do.
[PING]
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[END PLAYBACK]
Anyone speak Russian here?
Yeah, OK.
Hopefully, was that accurate?
AUDIENCE: Does it
do [INAUDIBLE]??
DAN AHARON: I don't think
so, but that's probably
coming soon.
Yeah, we haven't released
Text-to-Speech in India,
but stay tuned.
But anyway, yeah, if you
want more information
about this stuff, they will
launched this a while back--
whoops, sorry.
And 300,000 are already
sold-- so, pretty exciting.
Let me go back to the links.
And you can see there.
So while we're
doing that, I don't
think we have-- oh,
please leave feedback.
The organizers were very clear--
it would be great if we can get
as much feedback as possible
from as many of you.
Tell us if you
enjoyed the session.
Tell us if you didn't--
what you want to hear more,
what you want to hear less.
[MUSIC PLAYING]